I was gonna rest my little best in Joe
so uh oh [ __ ] my mic welcome oh [ __ ]
what's hatch those obviously an owl I
can't hurt me
alright so welcome back to I know what
that was been you know welcome no job
not it headed west
hahahaha Oh what is that what is that I
don't think this is safe
hi you got a level oh I doubt there's
another way around it anyway so uh-huh
uh-huh thank you - why doesn't sir I
call the camp oh [ __ ]
what is that noise god damn god damn Sam
how to lay oh I found the place right
away that's pretty cool um I wonder how
long this game is I'm really enjoying
the idea behind it it's a very cool
concept that everything is randomized
and you dig deeper for the as far as you
go I really like that um I don't know
what I'm talking about but that's great
Joe you're great Joe so I went all that
way for a 7 minute now I'm ski can I go
down there
Yolo oh I don't think you do that bad
soil ground soil I can't use that voice
man it hurts all right good job not hon
I was like oh it's coffins uh hey man
what it why I was just being polite
wait it keeps going I thought a minute
at a lab what is this kind of place
XM and xsplit Joe Joey and Brian Joe and
Brian is definitely behind this all
right so should I go there now there's
bushes there and like leashes ok ok
that's fine so sorry bushes I'll be I'll
be going this way better oh my god what
is happening oh god he's falling I can't
handle fall
am i alive I don't even did I what
Oh God oh shut up I think I died no I'm
a lot what hmm
what don't say that pit why what to
regenerate use a gold steak oh we didn't
have any we made it assume that Morocco
Laza oh is the shadow people I bet they
touch me okay it's all good
I hate for assistance get damn it uh oh
[ __ ] um okay that looks legit let's go
in there oh god is that a house in the
woods I need a drink some soda so nice
the best and all right well it's going
oh hello can I see my booty I'm going
this creepy house now oh oh it's like
spot that's kind of weird
hey I'll take it wait wait is this the
place we began and no Ganondorf Canyon
game yet what whatever what is wrong
with me
all right keep going inside and I'm sure
remnants no you're fine
I know that oh [ __ ] the door open that
means that's horror lingo for don't go
in there let's go in there [ __ ] yeah hi
people and if you think it's really dark
it is for me too
so don't give me that look man what a
fine ass b-word
don't spray okay hello what's up not
much
Barry whoa chaplain achievement allies
get scared by a lamb okay let's ask
wells on in here
Sara what the [ __ ]
I would
that's never going here again what I'm
locked now I came from I can't I can't
come day you can't lock me in hello
ladder can I go up nope
what is love baby
Oh what is what whoa
white
what is this don't like this don't wanna
close my eyes I don't wanna fall asleep
cause I don't Oh Oh Jacqueline darling
darling darling darling okay Shh
don't like the noises I don't like the
noises why would you don't know who
you're talking to I'm famous
let's go to the orgy I got damnit you
never have any fun alright what's the
final one
I get it my name is Todd got it
hi ladies how are you doing great
weather today it's been a lot better
lately I'm glad to meet you I'm gonna go
here can't go shut that comic daddy's
done [ __ ] up don't touch me and famous
famous here got a verified on Twitter
you just jealous
hi god dammit
jealous son of a [ __ ] crash my game
okay I hear you you're really annoying
alright what you do job La Raza dice
this skate it reach the joblessness skit
oh my god go now baby go it out baby
hold my head awakening I need you all my
hand [ __ ] what is happening oh you're
sweaty
God that's okay
I like it
that was really awesome it's a shame
this last video got a level short but I
still thought this is a really cool game
thanks a lot to stop with studios for
sending it to me uh I can't wait to play
this more actually because we I'm gonna
do for example they're still the feature
where you can live shooting the game and
you bros can control the scary so we're
just really awesome it's a legitimate
legit it whatever it's a really scary
game like it's been a while since I
played a game and I'm really struggling
to progress in it because it's just so
terrifying and I missed I that's what I
love about horror games just the
adrenaline of being scared and if this
is one thing the game nails it was the
atmosphere it was really truly terrified
to play there honestly I don't think a
lot of people would be able to pull
through with this game because it's that
terrifying
I would love split a and also to check
the story out better I mean it I don't
know I I just don't I know most people
don't like to that I read notes so
that's why I don't do it anymore
it's not to be disrespectful to the
developers and their writing is it's
only because I know most people hate me
picking up notes but yeah I'll see you
next livestream hopefully I can do that
soon
Thank You boys for watching this series
I'm proud of you we did it together we
hold our hands it's been we had some ups
and downs but it was a good time and I
had a lot of fun playing it regardless I
hope you had fun watching it that's all
that matters baby don't be brush thank
you for watching and here's certain
another great horror game Sam summers